I hope I'll get a sense of what's really
going on here from John's wife Tina
Gordon this is my lovely wife Howie I'm
stressed out well hotel were you running
before this I was running a dental
office I worked in a dental office I
wasn't running anything except my home
so why would you go from sort of team to
hotel because he bought a hotel so you
bought the hotel
it was my negotiation she negotiated you
both bought it yes willingly or
unwittingly
unwillingly I was very happy and content
with the life that we had so when John
told me that we were buying the
Roosevelt I burst into tears how much
did you buy for seven hundred thousand
seven how much you spent on we are 1
million one hundred thousand I see you
haven't paid back the debt yet the bank
owner huh sold our house they had here
cash in a 401k everything we had Oh what
was that where's your house now when you
live in banana land this is my help I
have had terrible experiences here
business experience financial hardship
everything's just falling apart here for
me
you seem serious you seem joking it's
almost like you're playing assets it is
kind of an entertainment though to a
certain degree at one point 1 million
dollars that's an expensive
entertainment well again I didn't
realize it was this bad
has a relationship we were in a rough
place we went through marriage
counseling I was at four or five years
ago because of this business
oh yeah and still working together seven
days a week yes 24/7 we met
I'm ready for something to change I'm
ready for anything
at this point I just feel like I'm gonna
suffocate oh yeah my bag your packs and
all there I'll catch you later
thank you Tina looks ready to bail out
and all John can do is laugh
he thing's been over a million dollars
in debt is entertainment
I think this marriage is in as much
trouble as the end clearly in denial but
more importantly a man that won't man up
and take responsibility I've been told
that tonight the Roosevelt in is holding
a murder mystery dinner is an event they
host once a month I have a feeling it's
gonna be hard to forget if you'll head
on into there I'll get you all checked
in when you go you're fabulous we
usually always have a lot of fun with
this we're going to continue and have
fun with this are you dressing that the
ceiling I play the part of Sherlock
Holmes oh man
you're playing an Englishman I am
playing Englishman I even have the pipe
to go with it I've studied this accent
long and hard in fact mine is better
than no edition actually don't know
where Gordon got his accent she
obviously doesn't practice it very much
- far more authentic than his is
absolutely
well while John prances around as
Sherlock Holmes
I wonder what Tina does during these
events what oh this is crazy
murder mystery night son it's gone from
an injured little house in Prairie will
be my job this evening to cook your
dinner so while John gets to play
Sherlock Holmes his wife is stuck in the
kitchen wake up John
this is not the 1800s anymore John
definitely like dressing up more for the
murder mysteries because he's not in the
hot kitchen he's out there hamming it up
with the guests playing Sherlock Holmes
okay slightly weird
I wonder if this event even makes any
money is this profitable it is
profitable yeah it's a lot of work I
mean we made $200 tonight $200 for
always worth and a little stain oh no
what's the locals you know when they
come from an investor they usually don't
do it overnight
clearly it's nice about feeding Jon's
ego not filling his bank account oh well
that could explain it I say the game is
afoot
you know their goal with the murder
mysteries has always been to get people
in but I'm not filling the rooms what's
the point of all of you
thank goodness that's over it's time to
find out from John what on earth he
thinks he's doing sit down
you must be shattered I'm tired I bet
you are stick a fork in me Matt was it
mad yeah you're in the kitchen busting
your ourselves working hard to sell all
those people and John you out prancing
around like a sort of access is a
pedestrian thing isn't in it's not a
theater but you seem to enjoy it you
have to force yourself to like doing it
I mean it's on stage for three hours the
problem that the roosevelt elementary
class the over the owner i'm sure this
place is sinking because john refuses to
take anything seriously you love being
an entertainer don't you dare tell me
that that is hardly this whole [ __ ]
thing was put together for your fantasy
well that's kind of what this night is
it is entertainment we put on a show
you're pretending to be Sherlock Holmes
and upstairs were empty during the sheet
financially we're in ruins and if you
put the same amount of effort into
filling this place just one room book
tonight would have made more profit than
the whole murder mystery and all that
work that went into it this is insane
and you prance around like some [ __ ]
idiot while your wife is slaving away in
the kitchen
Cheerilee care in the world apart for
yourself when you get a psychology
degree oh why don't you come and tell me
what's wrong with me
here we go you obviously think you are
psychologist denial again no I'm not in
denial I just don't know what you want
it's only your own [ __ ] stupidity -
why we're in the [ __ ] this bar well that
is probably true so then man up and act
responsible okay I'm done with that Oh
then with that in oh yeah no I just
talked to my hand you know man
oh what a [ __ ] idea ten years old you
need to grow up and stop running away
from the truth [ __ ] joke